[Music]
let's start it off this hour
in atlanta georgia sarah joins us sarah
how can we help
hi thanks for having me sure i have a
question for dr daley
so a few years ago
after i had given birth to my first
child
i was sent a message
and found out that i had a brother that
i didn't know existed
um and you know once i confronted my
parents
i don't think i was ever going to be
told um and it's just kind of
went away nobody wants to talk about it
um
and i've just had a really hard time
struggling with it ever since and i just
kind of don't really know
how to move forward i mean i know you
say forgive and forget um
but i can't even oh no you don't you
don't forget sarah you forgive right
right so why did they not tell you about
this brother
um i think there's a lot of reasons
the problem is that you kind of
get two different stories i think and i
think i've kind of pieced it together in
my head
but um it was you know it was before my
parents ever met
um so it you know it wasn't on the side
or anything like that it was it was
before that so it
you know he didn't have a relationship
with my
um father after they met really after we
were born
you know we never knew he never came
around um and
my parents just kind of say you know
that that
is over and he had a father who raised
him
and that's not a part of our life and
basically get over it move on so how can
i help you what are you struggling with
i'm going to try not to cry um well a
couple of things
reconciling the father
that i love and
was have always been very close to um
with this man who now you know i found
out has a child that he has no
relationship with
and that's decided all the men that i
knew and then also on the other hand
i've been pretty much given an ultimatum
by my mother that
i i cannot speak to him i cannot
have anything to do with him that that
will ruin our family and it will be my
fault
wow so
wow there's a lot here two things
one is um can obviously weigh in
one yeah the person you thought your dad
was is different
yeah um you thought he was a person of
excalibur of x integrity of x passed and
you found out that that was incorrect
i will tell you that most parents most
of the time are doing the best they can
with the tools they have at the time
they make decisions
that doesn't make it right that doesn't
make it
not painful or not hurtful sometimes
that takes
the edge off whether it's evil or not
okay
i don't know your dad that's between you
and him
so that's number one number two i
wholeheartedly with all of my heart and
mind and soul and body and spirit reject
the idea that i've got a brother out
there
that i'm forbidden to talk to right
okay that's putting you in a
i'm not in the business of talking bad
about people's moms but that puts you
in a position that is unfair is not
right
and i'm sorry that happened to you
because nobody should be put in that
position
period okay right for whatever reason
and we could probably talk for a couple
of weeks on this deal
that your brother is a source of shame
and frustration and embarrassment to
your mom and dad
and the way they have chosen to handle
that is to pretend it doesn't exist
right and that's not a mature way of
handling it that's not an adult way of
handling it
but that's the way they have chosen to
do it what you have to do is to choose
how you want to handle it
and what i'm telling you right now is if
i have a brother that i find out exists
somewhere
i will be on the phone i will be on an
airplane i will have an open front door
tomorrow okay so i can't tell you what
to do i'm going to tell you what i would
do
i can tell you that um i would recommend
all adults having hard conversations
with one another so if you haven't told
your dad how you feel
asked him why he didn't tell you
where his heart is tell him how you're
hurting but
yet you meet with him and hold him
hostage i'm going to tell you you need
to be better than that
okay going to war with your dad doesn't
help anybody it just leaves a pile of
bodies
okay sarah i just want to ask you a
quick question about your dad i i know
that there's this
story from your dad's life you didn't
know about but
was your dad a good dad to you the best
yes do you have a great relationship
with your dad prior to this information
coming out did you have a great
relationship yes
so i'm just gonna tell you that i don't
think he's a different guy all of a
sudden i just think you found out a part
of his life that you didn't know about
but
that does not discount the fact that he
was an awesome
dad to you that he still is an awesome
dad to you
and he's ashamed of what happened but
his shame did not
change his fathering of you in fact you
just said he was awesome
so here's a dude who was hurting deeply
yet still fathered you greatly
i don't think that changes anything that
would be my take
and so i think you do what john says but
i think you do it with just a sense of
i'm kind of confused and hurting a
little bit but
a lot right okay a lot but my point is
is that
is that so is he and yet he still was a
great dad to you and he still is and he
still can be
uh that would be my only comment as i
listened in i think you got to be
careful now with mom
uh mom is scared and mom is putting an
ultimatum on you because she doesn't
want this thing to come back up and it
surfaced without her
permission it surfaced without her
knowing about it and she's trying to
tamp it down
i think you could still honor her pain
and do what john said
but don't let her ultimatum stop you but
i'm gonna tell you something right now
grace and mercy all the times your dad
gave you grace and mercy now it's time
for you to pay him back
yes and i it's been a long time a long
time several years since i found it out
um and i just kind of had to bury it for
a while before i was ready to deal with
it
um um
and what you know wanted to meet and
have a relationship um
but then you know so how do i how do i
move forward with that like because
obviously
my boundaries have been sarah sarah i'll
tell you what we're going to do
we're going to put you on hold if you're
willing to hold on to the commercial
break
we're going to come back we're going to
pick this up dr deloney is going to tell
you
how to move forward with this john tell
our listeners who've just joined us
where we were with sarah and she's
rejoining us
so sarah make sure i've got this right
you
had your own baby you found out a few
years after having your kid
that you have a brother that you didn't
know was out there
and you are interested as most of us
would be
in connecting with your brother and
you've got two hard challenges number
one
you're struggling with a dad who loved
you who was a great father to you
but that held this deep secret that you
never knew about
that kept you from blood relationships
and you're wondering who is he can i
trust him
is he the man i thought he was and
you're also wrestling with a mom who's
given you an ultimatum
which is we're going to go on as a
family as though our brother your
brother doesn't exist
and if you reach out to him you're i'm
done with you too
so hearing that recap from a neutral
third party
a couple of guys you just met how does
that sound back to you
so many emotions um just it's
just painful sure but it would be that
easy to
tell me that so here's a couple of
suggestions that i want you to think
through
following up with what ken said and he
was very very wise here we live in a
culture
that is one and done that is
you get one mistake and you can't work
here anymore
you can't be in my family anymore you
can't come to my church anymore we are a
one and done culture
and quite frankly i'm sick of it
because most people are doing the best
they can with what limited
blunt tools they've got in their toolkit
and most of us got our tools from our
parents
who are trying the best they could and
they got them from their parents and so
on
and so the question you have and it's
really an easy
either or for you is
do you want to forgive your dad do you
want to have a hard conversation with
him and say i'm interested in learning
about
why you did what you did he might not be
able to tell you
i'm interested in all of the wonderful
great father attributes you had but i'm
struggling with this one thing
and that's you being vulnerable in
relationship with him
and giving him a chance to talk for
himself and then you have a decision to
make
do i want that man in my life dwell him
in his grand grandchild's life
or not it's an either or thing and i
wish it could be simple
and uh it is simple i wish it could be
pain-free
all of those options are going to hurt
sarah they're all going to be hard
the second thing is you've got to decide
are you going to call your mom's bluff
or not
are you going to not reach out to your
brother because she has shown
she can wipe somebody clean off her
slate and be done with them right
yes most of the time when parents make
threats like that i smile and say go
meet your brother your mom's not gonna
do that to you
your mom's done it before it could
happen i don't think it will
but it could happen just knowing that
the
deep shame deep pain that your mom feels
around him
is real right so do i
tell her that's a decision for you
i'm somebody who doesn't live my life
with secrets i don't like to live my
life behind closed doors
i don't either um i also i also
don't wander into fires unnecessarily so
maybe you call your brother
you get to talk to him you get to meet
him you get to know
him um and that doesn't have to be
something that you immediately hand up
the phone and call mom and say ha ha
guess what i did just to rub her nose in
it
but i also am never in the business of
lying to my mom and dad
yeah what do you want out of this sarah
what would be an ideal situation
um i'm someone who loves family and
loves everyone
i'm a i'm a type 2 i'm a helper i
like to make people happy i like to open
my home and have people there
and everyone enjoying each other
and i just know that that's not a
possibility in this situation
um so i don't even know um i just
i guess want it to be okay for me to
have feelings that i have
and be able to do what i want without
being told
what i have to do and that i'm the one
who is going to make
this into the bad situation when i
didn't ask for this
so sarah how old are you
in my 30s okay well
great avoidance there that was excellent
so i want you to imagine
what your mom said to you what your mom
did to you
as she hot potatoed you a giant cinder
block
and you caught it with two hands and she
told you
if you put this on the ground everything
falls apart and it's your fault
and i want you to know that's inaccurate
don't carry that brick
put it down and then the second thing i
want you to do is i want you to grieve
the loss of the picture you had of your
family because it's now
over there's a period at the end of that
i'd recommend getting a couple of
friends that you trust and literally
have a ceremony
it's over and then you can be about
making what your new family is going to
look like
you get to choose on this end who's
going to be a part of it well that's
going to be your brother what's going to
be your mom your dad
you get to make those decisions
affirmatively but if you don't grieve
the end of what that picture was
your brain's going to keep chasing it
you're going to get anxious you're going
to have that low-level
depression that low-level things aren't
right it's going to be a low-level fire
that burns throughout your living room
for the rest of your life
until you end that picture right right
john i have a question for you
on behalf of sarah yeah
would it be helpful for her to meet with
her dad separately
absolutely 100 knows the whole back
story yep
and it's probably going to give it the
give her all the details to try to
understand
why mom is so wanting to keep this
separate
would that help sarah understand mom's
pain
yes and why not that it's not cool that
mom did what she did but we also want
sarah i want sarah to at least
understand maybe why mom
is so sure adamant absolutely sarah
would your dad have a private
conversation with you
yes my guess is mom has directed him on
what he should be doing too is that
right
100 okay because sarah i'm sorry i there
was a lot of details coming at this was
your mom's
biological child with another man not
your dad the opposite
huh the opposite oh it's your dad okay
oh it's your dad's biological child with
a different woman
yes oh well then okay now i know the
answer okay i
i and i was slightly off and that's why
i asked the clarifying question
uh but yeah i still think you should
talk with your dad and let him express
why your mom feels the way she does um
and she feels like to me john that she
that
that sarah's mom put her father in this
this is how it's going to be
sure and and she wants to have the ideal
picture of relationship in her head and
she wants to keep that
facade going as long as she can yeah um
sarah i'm going to recommend you
tell your dad a few weeks out that
you're going to come over to his house
or you invite him to your house
if y'all can do this civilly you're
going to go meet in a restaurant and i
want you to
write out what you want to accomplish
from that meeting
going to beat up your dad for something
that happened 20 30 years ago is not
going to be helpful
going there and just being angry isn't
going to be super helpful being angry is
okay
that just points you towards something
that you care about right but being
being a hurricane in that meeting is not
going to be fruitful or helpful and
you're going to walk away frustrated
yeah showing up that meeting with some
ideas on what you want to accomplish
what you want to get from
and wanting to listen to your dad's
heart and making sure he
he hears your feelings because they are
valid um
and then follow up with your brother and
then john we only got a minute here but
i i'm just
i mean what if she finds out that you
know what this this
she wants to meet this brother she wants
to meet this this half brother
i get it but if mom's not in a place for
that
you know is it okay to look at the
timing of that and go we got to try that
mom and i got to reconnect and we got to
get to a point where mom understands why
i want to do it not just go
do it that's my concern i don't want to
ruin the relationship with mom because
mom's not healthy
and what i what i think is happening
here is mom's making the ultimatum i
agree so my mom's the one who's going to
hold the consequence of this
relationship i don't want sarah's
mom her relationship with her mom to be
totally destroyed
i would preach patience to sarah on
meeting the brothers but i think
i think their relationship's fractured
now no question because of the ultimatum
no question
it's a sticky situation wow we praying
for you sarah yeah thank you for
trusting us thank you for calling